[Musique]
landau journaliste infiltré une soirée
clandestine organisé hier près du
périphérique une centaine de personnes
alcoolisées sans masque
comme un air de relâchement en
témoignent ces images tournées rue
debussy à paris des centaines de
parisiens rassembler pour des apéritifs
sauvage j'entends du bruit abandonné 1
font un fond musical
je me dirige alors à l'oreille entre
guillemets et j'arrive dans une très
grande salle une très très grande salle
qui s'était véritablement transformé en
club ce soir là
très à nouveau je vous demande de bien
porter votre masque
il y avait une centaine de personnes
devant mes yeux qui dansaient sans
aucune
comment dire exactement là on voit pas
beaucoup de masques al ala je vous le
dit justement les personnes me regarder
bizarrement car j'étais quasiment le
seul à porter le masque sur les réseaux
sociaux la préfecture de police annonce
que le matériel sono a été saisi et les
cinq organisateurs interpellé et
s'immisce vivait ses dernières heures de
liberté avant un confinement de
nouvelles restrictions seront annoncés
dans les prochaines heures dans la
cinquième ville de france où les gestes
barrières semblent moins respectée
depuis quelques jours hier les résultats
chiffre n'était pas bon de l'épidémie à
l'échelle du pays
il y avait plus de trois mille cas
supplémentaires par rapport au vendredi
de la semaine précédente
on ne fait pas une politique de santé
sur la base de chiffres d'une journée ni
de deux jours mais je vous le dis
l'heure actuelle attendant sur les trois
derniers jours n'est pas bonne il ya
plusieurs pistes qui ont été annoncées
renforcement du couvre-feu un
confinement le week-end un confinement
total du département je vais pas moi
vous dire quelle est la piste qui a été
retenue alors que la concertation est
toujours en cours entre ce que ce sera
annoncé aussi pour moi pour qu'ils
sachent quand je crois que la
concertation doit s'achever aujourd'hui
est que ce sera annoncée soit ce soir
soit demain ce serait mieux qu'un
confinement généralisée absolument
absolument surtout quand les élus locaux
ont cette demande d'un confinement
localiser ça a été le cas en moselle à
metz a été le cas dans le dunkerquois
on a ce débat au niveau de nice comme on
souhaite tous éviter le confinement
généralisée il est important quand même
de traiter l'urgence sanitaire de
youtube heures ont reçu un message vidéo
d' emmanuel macron bonjour à tous les
deux j'espère que vous allez bien
alors je sais que d'habitude c'est vous
les spécialistes et des filles on n'est
pas vraiment dans une concertation on
est dans une information bienveillante
mais une information donc je crois
pouvoir dire que effectivement les deux
prochains week-ends seront des week-ends
de confinement donc la décision est déjà
prise
fait cette vidéo toute simple si vous
avez 10 millions de vues je prends un
engagement
vous venez tourné à l'elysée 10 millions
de vues pour nous aider à battre le
virus
à vous de jouer pour nous faire plaisir
évidemment qu'il a bon mais voilà il ya
un choix politique en france qui est le
choix de je dirais de maintenir un
niveau économique a baissé mais moins
abc que le confinement total est de
maintenir un haut niveau de circulation
du virus qui est le cas actuellement sur
les réseaux sociaux l'initiative
présidentielles divisent
on a fait quoi sérieusement pour en
arriver là à devoir emmanuel macron dans
une vidéo de mac faye et carlito ça va
être incroyable je propose qu'à 20
millions de vues il puisse filmer les
files d'attentes des étudiants qui n'ont
pas à manger
voici l'image à laquelle ont été
confrontés les passagers quelques
minutes après un décollage vers midi une
explosion retentit au niveau du réacteur
droit de ce triple sept de la compagnie
united airlines en route pour honolulu à
hawaï
l'avion doit se poser immédiatement
le pilote parvint finalement tant bien
que mal à à l'aéroport de denver au
grand soulagement des passagers